all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and as promised we are back with
Days of Future Past Doomsday the
conclusion of the story and the
eradication of the mutant population on
Earth now what this does here right for
those of you guys who are just now
picking up at the end of this video I'll
have a link to a playlist where you can
catch the first video that we did that
kind of ran over everything but in
effect we're at year 33 33 years after
the assassination of Senator Robert
Kelly the reactivation of the Sentinel
program which basically became
self-aware and Sentinels taking over
North America and enslaving the mutant
and human population and so what
happened is that somewhere along the
line basically in what was formerly
asteroid M which was at one point a base
of operations for Magneto that it has
now become a prison for the mutant
population now that's one of the big
differences between the original Days of
Future Past and this one and the
original Days of Future Past and in fact
we'll actually get to that point in the
story that main internment camp was
actually in New York right but what
ended up going on here is that when the
Sentinels first started capturing
mutants and they set up this internment
camp that what they did is they created
a kind of central Hub right a kind of
Mainframe computer and that computer
controlled the inhibitor collars that
all the mutants wore right the collars
that basically shut their powers down
some kind of a riot took place where the
mutants were able to destroy the Central
Computer they reactivated their powers
and they went to war against the
Sentinels and for a moment they were
winning for a moment they were winning
and it looked like the day was saved but
then reinforcements arrived now this is
another big difference right in this
moment what you see here is a
combination of Mark 1 and Mark 2
Sentinels along with nimrods now the big
difference between the original Days of
Future Past and this Days of Future Past
is that in the original story the reason
why the Sentinels were able to take over
North America and really wipe out most
of the superhero Community is because
there were just so many of them right
like they just multiplied like crazy so
there were thousands tens of thousands
of Sentinels traveling around North
America so any attempt by any remaining
members of the Superhuman or even human
population that tried to fight Sentinels
found themselves in a war of attrition
the Sentinels would just keep coming and
coming and coming eventually these guys
would be worn down and they would either
be captured or killed the Nimrod
Sentinels didn't appear until much later
on in the Days of Future Past Universe
we didn't figure that out until the
story Days of Future present which we'll
talk about a little bit as we get
towards the end of this because it's
really cool the important thing here is
that there were seemingly only two
mutants Left Alive in this Riot the
first one was Laura Kenny x23 who pretty
much all of you guys know about and the
other one was sink right Everett Thomas
now Everett Thomas has grown more
popular at least in more recent years
since Jonathan Hickman's reworking of
the X-Men Mythos but this guy is
ridiculously overpowered especially now
because his powers have evolved but in
essence he can duplicate the powers of
anybody who's near him a great big
caveat that was adjusted or kind of a
boost to his power that was given
recently is that there's no limit to how
long he can hold on to that power for so
he could walk through like a field of
mutants copy all their abilities and
then hold on to those Powers seemingly
for the rest of his life so the guys
like Peter patrelli from Heroes back in
the if you guys remember that show and
so this whole event is actually told to
Franklin Richards Magneto storm Rachel
summmer Colossus is told to them by
Kitty Pride she's kind of hearing it all
or at least repeating it all to them
because she heard it secondhand it just
happened over there off the coast of San
Francisco nobody really knows for sure
who survived or anything but following
that whole event that's when you start
to fall more in line with the
traditional Days of Future Past story
where each one of the mutants had an
inhibitor collar that had to be turned
off individually so there was no main
frame to destroy the only way to get
your powers back was to destroy your own
inhibitor collar but if you did that it
would detonate and it would kill you so
just because of the fact that none of
the mutants wanted to die they were
stuck with really these inhibitor
collars around their necks and so what's
going on here is really kind of like
this dovetail into the original
conclusion of Days of Future Past where
Kitty Pride if you recall in the
previous video and again you'll find a
link to that at the end of this video
Kitty Pride had come across Bishop now
Bishop traditionally a time traveling
mutant did not appear in the original
Days of Future Past because he was not
introduced in Marvel at that point in
time right he wasn't introduced in
Marvel until what is it Uncanny X-Men
286 289 maybe it was 287 something like
that uh but he was introduced much later
on right in the 80s late 80s going into
the early 90s but the kicker about all
this is that Bishop had told Kitty Pride
you guys need to find a way to time
travel it's the only way for you to save
save your current Universe now before a
lot of you guys kind of get dismissive
and you're like oh my god really time
travel hyenes don't worry Marvel does
not disappoint they do not disappoint
and in fact the ending to this is not
like the original Days of Future Past
that's the one hint I'll give you and so
what this does is this transitions over
to the Atlantic Ocean and the reason why
is because in order for this plan to
work these remaining XI right Kitty
pride and everybody else they need to be
able to deactivate their inhibitor
collar but Reed Richards of the Fant CLC
4 is dead he was killed in the last
video Iron Man was killed in the last
video there's no one out there right
Hank Pim Ant-Man all these guys Bruce
Banner there's nobody else out there
with the level of wherewithal and the
technological prowess to deactivate
these callers except for one guy Forge
now for those of you guys who areen
familiar with Forge and I imagine
there's probably a few people who are
not Forge is basically a mutant whose
power basically turns him into Tony
Stark that's really what it is if you
take away his mutant power he doesn't
really know how to do anything but with
his mut power he's just this genius
technological inventor but because of
his capabilities the Sentinels didn't
kill him instead they've been using him
as a guy that can help them Advance
their own machinery and Advance their
own capabilities now this is also
another big difference between the
original Days of Future Past if this was
part of that story it was never readily
explained in Chris claremont's original
run and Uncanny X-Men 141 and 142 the
only thing we really knew is that
because the Sentinels were
technologically advanced and because
they were self-aware they took over the
backer building the former home base of
the Fantastic 4 and they used all the
technology in the backer building to
enhance themselves but because they were
just machines right they were like the
machines from The Matrix right like the
longer they existed the more advanced
they became just by understanding their
own components and evolving from there
right self-aware and autonomous so it is
a kind of cool little addition to this
but because Forge is so necessary here
word had been sent to Wolverine who's
part of the Canadian resistance which is
an accurate part of the original Days of
Future Past and that the idea here is
that he would basically sneak in and he
would get Forge out now the reason why
this works both in the original and in
this one is because it's wolver rain
right Marvel is actually building off
Daniel way Wolverine Origins run that's
how this works if you guys aren familiar
with that Wolverine Origins by Daniel
way was the story where Wolverine got
all of his memories back after the
events of House of M and so he went on
this kind of like war path but one of
the things that he had done is he
successfully snuck into the White House
and then eventually left and did it
without being caught and so the guy can
get in and out of basically anywhere but
once he gets in here because Sentinels
are not like humans meaning there's very
very little that they ever actually miss
Wolverine gets forg he basically helps
him at least to try to initiate the
Escape but he tells him getting in is
not the problem it's getting out now you
would think a way in is a way out but
whatever means he used to get in here is
seemingly not available to him as
they're trying to leave but the nimrods
immediately pick up on what it is that
these guys are doing right they're here
and they're trying to stage and escape
and so because of the fact that there's
really no way out for both of them Forge
does the only thing he can do right he
says I'll stay behind to destroy this
terminal so the Sentinels will not know
what I've designed and then I'll cover
your Escape now here's the kicker behind
this Forge has been working on more than
simply just a way to deactivate
inhibitor collar he's been working on a
kind of technology that would actually
allow the entirety of the remaining
mutant population to escape their
confinement and wage war against the
Sentinels but here's the caveat to this
there's a ticking Time Bomb here quite
literally the rest of the world has come
to the realization of the threat that
the Sentinels pose because remember what
we covered in the last video is that
despite the fact that Sentinels were
activated by humans to track down
mutants and to basically capture them in
North America the Sentinels rationalized
with the only real logic that they could
use that because mutants were at the
next stage in human evolution mutants
are humans and so Sentinels tracked down
both and they took over the entirety of
North America the rest of the world
right especially Europe came to the
realization if the Sentinels Escape
North America and they're able to impose
their will across the rest of the world
everybody will be captured every single
human every single superpowered being
the whole nine yards so what the rest of
the world is currently planning is a
nuclear strike against North America to
eradicate the entirety of the Sentinel
population which would happen right they
would be able to destroy pretty much all
Sentinels and even if they didn't
destroy all the Sentinels they would
wipe out enough that their numbers would
count for nothing so it's one of those
really like okay we have only so long to
do this and so one of the things that
goes on here is that the Sentinels
themselves what they'v been doing is
that because they had become more
advanced as time had gone on that they
had basically become larger and larger
and because of that there were certain
tasks that they simply just were not fit
to do they couldn't really go out there
into the world and scavenge for parts
anymore to grab resources and things
that were needed for Forge to do his
work or whatever else and so what they
were doing is they were grabbing mutants
and they were sending them out and
saying get these components get what we
need and then come back right if you
don't if you're not back within 3 hours
we'll activate your inhibitor collars
and we'll kill you right that's
basically it and so the mutants were
more right Aon boys Aaron girls that's
really the purpose that they served but
what the Sentinels didn't realize is
that this offered the mutant population
this kind of unsupervised time where
they can actually actively work against
the Sentinels themselves now one of the
things that's kind of cool here is that
it almost gives the Sentinels this air
of arrogance right like who are these
mutants to believe they could overtake
us and in fact that's accurate right in
the original Days of Future Past and in
this one as the Sentinels become more
self self aare they begin to develop
almost human emotions they become
arrogant right that's kind of how they
began to evolve and began to grow and so
what they end up doing is Kitty Pride
meets with Wolverine he passes the thumb
drive off to her and the project or what
it was that uh Forge was working on was
basically a Jammer so instead of simply
just shutting down an inhibitor collar
that this Jammer would be able to shut
down multiple collars at once which is a
far more productive method of allowing
mutants the ability to use their powers
because instead of like running around
with a little key right and like trying
to make contact with 50 little mutants
and trying to turn off their inhibitor
callars and so on they just take this
thing sit it down turn it on and
everybody can use their powers now right
and one Fell Swoop the entirety of the
mutant population goes back to the way
they were without having to worry about
the inability to being able to use their
abilities against the Sentinels and so
this is when they really start to get
into the realm of time travel because
much like the original Days of Future
Past story because Rachel Summers is the
daughter of Cyclops and Gan gray in Days
of Future Past she has vast telepathic
powers and in fact this kind of brings
in right really kind of dovet tales
nicely into Days of Future present Days
of Future present while it's not part of
this story it seemingly leads into it
but Days of Future present was a story
that was told in Marvel Comics back in
the80s that basically explained how it
was that Rachel Summers arrived in the
main Marvel Universe and we'll talk
about that a little more as we get
towards the end of this because you guys
are going to kind of find yourselves in
a sort of precarious position I'm
curious to see how you guys respond to
it if you never read the original Days
of Future Past but this whole plan this
was the idea of Bishop right it was like
Bishop's idea have someone send your
mind into the past into the younger body
of yourself because if your physical
body goes back there you could get stuck
any number of things could go wrong but
by sending your mind into the past
especially with like a telepath like
Rachel summmer she serves as an anchor
she can yank you back right it's a
tether that kind of thing and so Kitty
Pride's mind goes into the body of her
younger self and for those of you guys
who read the original Days of Future
Past this is all familiar to you so I'm
going to cover this more for the people
who never read the original story so
you're not left hanging because it's a
landmark Story the most iconic X-Men
Story Ever Told honestly I think it's
better than the dark Phoenix Saga but
being quite Frank with you guys but
that's because I love it when there's
like death pandemonium in the end of
times in Marvel Comics when everybody
dies
I love those stories and so Kitty
Pride's mind going into the body of her
younger self when she was like what like
15 I think it was maybe like like 12 or
13 when she first joined the X-Men she's
able to stop the assassination of
Senator Robert Kelly and as soon as that
happens her mind is yanked back and so
one of the things that is a little bit
different here is that unlike the
original Days of Future Past where she
goes back and kind of meets with the
X-Men and gets to know them and all that
kind of stuff you get that to a degree
here but it's kind of passed over super
fast and I think a lot of that is
because Marvel's kind of relying on
people to understand the original Days
of Future Past all that really means
here is that when Kitty's mind went back
into the past in the original Days of
Future Past story that she actually
spent a few days like a week or so with
the X-Men basically saying hey this is
going to happen at this point in time
here in a little while you guys need to
be prepared for it right she actually
spent time learned about the X-Men
different things along those lines and
then took those lessons back with her
into the future and that's exactly what
happens here but there was also a plan B
because there was no guarantee that her
going into the past and changing it
would change the future and we'll talk
about why that matters here in a second
because Marvel invokes Branch universe
theory both in the original Days of
Future Past and in this one and so what
happens as part of this plan B is that
with the inhibitor collar deactivated by
way of the Jammer it allows them to
remove the inhibitor collars proper and
then stage their attempt Escape against
the Sentinel now much like the original
Days of Future Past basically everybody
dies right like storm is able to help
them save off the Sentinels for a little
while Magneto stays behind in his
wheelchair to basically cover their
Escape right like it's one of those
things where they're kind of like I mean
look his wheelchair would have slowed us
down he made the right call to stay
behind right the Sentinels come out of
nowhere they annihilate Franklin Richard
here's a big kicker because this is
something that a lot of people asked
about with Franklin Richards in the
original Days of Future Past and the
stories that came out after because one
of the things that a lot of people don't
know about Franklin is that with Days of
Future Past he was just introduced as
the son of Reed and Susan but his whole
like crazy level reality warping Powers
right that wasn't until much later on so
a lot of people asked the question if
Franklin Richards by virtue of the
establishment of his reality warping
Powers when he was an adult if he was so
incredibly powerful why is that he was
destroyed by the Sentinels the only real
explanation Marvel and even us as the
fan base were able to offer was twofold
either one in this universe he never
attained that level of power he never
really became this crazy reality warping
character or if he did none of the
events transpired in his history that
led to him realizing he had that power
right so the old Fantastic 4 story when
he was frustrated working with a Rubik's
Cube and aged himself up into an adult
what is it Fantastic 4 145 or 146
something like that that story never
happened right so like he never realized
he could alter reality none of those
things took place The abraxis Saga never
took place Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers never took place right because
most of the superheroes were dead by
that point and so again it's one of
these things where he was a telepath and
telekinetic but that was basically it he
didn't have his crazy reality warping
Powers but the long and short of this is
that this guy's destroyed right so two
of them are down Rachel Summers being
the love interest of Franklin she kind
of stays behind a little bit right and
just kind of continues to attack the
Sentinels using a combination of her
telepathy and telekinesis which creates
a kind of psionic blast that just blows
the head off off of one of these
Sentinels but again their goal is to
basically keep moving forward is to find
a way to attack the Sentinels main base
of operations I.E the backer building
and so as they get there much like the
original Days of Future Past right
Wolverine as soon as he enters into the
backer building one of the Sentinels
immediately attacks him and that's
because they knew they were coming right
the Sentinels were well aware of the
fact that they were coming now what
really went on here is that Wolverine
and those guys ended up tripping a
sensor right that really alerted the
Sentinels to their presence and the
Sentinels just incinerated Wolverine on
the spot now this is one of the other
things about Days of Future Past when
the story was originally done and what
this story is really kind of building on
is the fact that Wolverine's healing
Factor had not become what it is now
back during the days of Chris
claremont's X-Men Wolverine's healing
Factor was more practical than anything
else right it wasn't like it is in Civil
War where his whole body is annihilated
and he just heals right and then like
that's it and his healing Factor becomes
like a plot device to a story no no no
no it was a fairly reasonable healing
factor and so that's why in this story
he's incinerated entirely and he doesn't
heal back from it right he's incinerated
all the way down to his adamantium
skeleton it's not to the point where
it's like well all you need is a cell
and then he'll heal back from everything
no it's not like that anymore of course
storm launches an attack Storm's impaled
with a spear and then Colossus goes to
make an attack on one of the Sentinels
now unlike the original Days of Future
Past where all you see with Colossus is
that goes to attack one of the Sentinels
and he's seemingly killed and thrown out
of a window this is where things begin
to shift because unlike the original
Days of Future Past where it's the end
of times for everybody Magneto
survived Magneto made it out against
those four Sentinal and why wouldn't he
right and I think that's one of the best
decisions about this is because like
sure Magneto is older but like four
Sentinels no man like four Sentinels are
not enough power to take out the master
of magnetism right like their entire
body is composed of of an element he can
use as a weapon like literally metal
they are their own destruction in the
eyes of Magneto so that guy took out
those four Sentinels he arrives on the
scene and then he goes after these four
Sentinels and in fact he seemingly seems
to issue kind of like an EMP to a degree
but one of the Sentinels which is
basically in the process of failing and
deactivating grabs Colossus and then
squeezes him to the point where his body
B basically just crushes now that is one
of the things to understand about
Colossus his organic metal skin is
actually called osmium it is not
indestructible it's not like adamantium
or vibranium or something along those
lines it is highly resistant to extreme
high and extremely low temperatures but
given the nature of the Sentinels the
strength that they possess in an effort
to basically take out guys like the
Incredible Hulk and people like that
sure they were able to destroy this
guy's body pretty well but that's when
Kitty Pride wakes up and ultimately it
comes to this realization nothing in the
Future Has Changed now that's where the
original Days of Future present came
into play because the belief with the
original Days of Future Past is that by
stopping the assassination in the past
everything in the future would just
cease to exist much like the movie right
if if you guys remember in the movie
that Wolverine succeeded that the
assassination was stopped and everybody
just vanished right and everything just
went back as if it never was like that
future never happened that's not how it
exists here the argument that Marvel
created here is they said okay in order
to avoid a paradox it doesn't make any
sense logically for the X-Men to go to
the past and stop the assassination that
creates the future that they just came
from it doesn't make any sense how do
you square that Circle it's going to
leave people baffled and nonsensical so
what Marvel does is they create a branch
Universe they say in order for the
entire reason for Kitty Pride to go into
the past to even exist in the first
place that future has to exist Days of
Future Past has to exist and so what
that meant is that by stopping the
assassination the guaranteed future of
the main Marvel universe is no longer
Days of Future Past right now it's just
whatever form that future takes based on
whatever things transpire over the
course of the main Marvel universe's
timeline Days of Future Past is now an
alternate reality it's now a what if
what if the assassination had gone
through and no one had been there to
stop it that becomes Days of Future Past
that's how that works when it comes to
Branch universe and Marvel and so
because of this they are basically now
living in an alternate reality and
because of that their effort is to find
a way to just like stop and annihilate
the entirety of the Sentinel forces
because if they don't Europe and the
rest of the world will nuke North
America and so as they go on this
Mission they end up tracking down what's
called the high Sentinel Trinity
basically these three Sentinels that
govern everything now that is also a big
difference it wasn't necessarily
established at that point in time in the
original Days of Future Past but you
ended up learning about a sentinel
called Master Mold this Sentinel that
creates other Sentinels kind of a funny
little tidbit here there was a story in
the 1990s called uh operation Zero
Tolerance where you basically ended up
coming across a guy named Bastion who
was the result of the Nimrod Sentinel
from Daisy Future Past traveling to the
present and merging with master mold in
the present day and creating a whole new
guy operation Zero Tolerance was dope
that was really good it was almost as
good as Extinction agenda right it was a
really good the '90s were a great time
to read X-Men to be honest with you guys
we need to cover like X-Men in the 9s
that's what we need to do '90s X-Men
Comics it was a great time and so what
this does is it basically leads to the
resistance force making its move the
cool thing is we have Magneto we've got
Rachel Summers in her traditional outfit
right black with the ponytail the whole
nine yards the one that she's the most
synonymous with from like her original
appearances Bishop is here of course
alongside uh Kitty pride and then we
also find out that in and Laura Kenny
both survive and these guys race into
this conflict against the Sentinels in
order to destroy them but we don't find
out what happens because that's the end
of the story with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end if
you need to get caught up make sure you
click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later it's one crazy
Cliffhanger isn't it peace